les premières mosquées
en 1892 les commerçants musulmans de
saint-denis achète un terrain rue
maréchal leclerc pourrait construire une
mosquée il finança construction en
prélevant un pourcentage sur leurs
bénéfices commerciaux
elle est inaugurée en 1905 détruit par
un incendie le bâtiment donnant sur la
rue est remplacé par le bâtiment actuel
en 1979 un minaret
le second de lille est construit à cette
occasion décoré de plaques de marbre
blanc et de petits carreaux de couleur
verte
cet édifice abrite des commerces au
rez-de-chaussée on pénètre dans la cour
des ablutions par une entrée discrète
ses piliers colonnes d'ordre toscan sont
les ultimes vestiges de la première
mosquée les arcs en accolade d'
influence orientale ont été ajoutés dans
les années 1960 plus vieille mosquée de
france
la mosquée nour et islam lumière de
l'islam fut longtemps l'unique au lieu
de culte pour les musulmans de saint
denis avant la construction à partir des
années 1980 d'autres mosquées
situé au centre ville de saint pierre la
mosquée attia bull massa dgid
littéralement la plus belle des mosquées
a été construit dans les années 70 à
l'emplacement de celle de 1913
dessiné par l'architecte d'origine russe
vladimir fritzl elle mélange les styles
de l'art musulman universel
d'une superficie de 625 mètres carrés sa
salle de prière est décoré de
calligraphie et de sculptures réalisées
par des artistes comme ou rien
son toit formé de cinq dôme est surmonté
d'un minaret s'élevant à plus de 40
mètres